many staffing changes at the White House
recently and there's talk of more to
come for president Trump is dismissing
shake up rumors as exaggerated following
the abrupt dismissal of his Secretary of
State
they wrote a story about staff changes
today that was very false we made a
wonderful change I think Mike Pompeo is
gonna be an incredible Secretary of
State we have some wonderful ideas I've
gotten to know a lot of people over the
last year you know I've been in
Washington for a little bit more than a
year where some people have been here
for 30 40 years I've gotten to know
great people so they'll always be
changed but very little it was a very
false story it was very very exaggerated
a very exaggerated and false story but
they'll always be change and I think you
want to see change and I want to also
see different ideas Larry Cutler just
came in a little while ago and I think
Larry is going to be outstanding as
economic adviser so we look forward to
it more now with chief White House
correspondent John Roberts John
Kimberley good afternoon to you not sure
exactly which report the private
President is referencing there is a
false report but Fox News was saying
last night and earlier today that there
were some expected staff changes ahead
they may number anywhere between two and
four depending on the timing and we were
told by sources inside and close to the
White House but outside yesterday that
some of these changes were imminent a
couple of the changes that have been
talked about there's an awful lot of
chatter about this one Secretary of
Veterans Affairs dr. David Shulkin may
be removed from his post we are told by
numerous officials in the White House
and people outside that he has lost the
confidence of the president to some
degree based on the findings of an
inspector general's report as well as
the travel where he had taxpayers foot
the bill
to take his wife to Europe he later
reimbursed the Treasury for that but the
president has always made Veterans
Affairs a real priority and if he's got
somebody in there who he doesn't think
is managing it as well as it could be
managed that he might make a change
there were some rumors yesterday that
Rick Perry the Secretary of Energy might
be the replacement but I'm told by White
House officials that both the president
and Perry have said he's not moving to
the VA
so another name that is floating to the
surface one that will be very familiar
to viewers of Fox News Pete hagseth who
used to be the CEO of concerned Veterans
of America and is well versed in
veterans issues and how to restructure
the VA Fox and Friends host his name is
as making the rounds again here at the
White House is a possible replacement
for children a couple of other items
that that may be in the offing sooner
rather than later HR McMaster the
National Security Advisor has been
rumored to not have a great relationship
with the president for a long time that
there's possibility he could leave in
the John Bolton the former US ambassador
to the United Nations may take his place
when it comes to the VA Sarah Huckabee
Sanders earlier today was asked about
any staff changes here's what she said I
don't have any personnel announcements
but I can tell you that every day we're
looking for how we can better the system
whether it's through policy changes or
personnel changes not just at the top
level but across the board we've already
made a number of changes within the
personnel and made sure that we're
looking at how we can best serve our
nation's veterans but the president
again saying that such talk about
changes is a false story but I'm told by
some people that he's getting tired
kimberley of these daily stories of the
drip drip drip of staff departures in
the chaos and better to rip the band-aid
off all at once get it all out of the
way then regroup and keep going forward
okay what seems a little bit like that
Gina John thank you so much all right
Dana so lots of developments we've been
hearing kind of a steady stream of
information about people that might be
exiting the White House different people
that perhaps the president didn't feel
that the relationship was gelling in the
way or perhaps it's just time to move on
so there's quite a it's almost like a
Broadway play at this point but like the
cast of characters that keeps developing
in terms of you know who might be
leaving in what order progression and
who the possible candidates and
replacements are from a communication
perspective what do you think of the way
this is sort of being disseminated and
handled or and how could perhaps they do
it better well I think that every
president should have people working for
him or her that they can trust him that
they have confidence in and change is
not necessarily bad but from a
communication standpoint the easiest
story to cover in Washington is
personnel changes and
if you want to force the media to cover
your accomplishments then you're going
to have to like serve them vegetables
but if you are serving up everyday
anonymous sources about somebody's in
somebody's out and then having the
president talk about it then it is
likely that they're going to eat dessert
first it's inevitable okay well there we
go
all right Greg I guess it feels more
like a business and less of a
bureaucracy because bureaucracy we can
get pretty comfortable bring in your box
and pictures and photos put it on your
desk you can't do that with Trump you
don't know what's gonna happen I I you
know I have to adjust my lens for the
last 18 months of what this White House
is like and I guess in this Trump era I
will take staff chaos over you know
stylized videos of decapitations of
Western Westerners and journalists I
mean if this is the kind of news that we
are covering I don't mind it I'd rather
hear about the staff changes it's it's
to me it's just part of life it's you
know it's better than seeing Isis every
day I think this is progress
okay all right Jesse well you called it
a Broadway play and I put the cast into
groupings because that's how I
understand things so you have the
Nationalists the Bandon sessions in the
Millers the businessman Cohn Ross
minuchin and Tillerson the establishment
rights and Spicer we know what happened
to them they have the Loyalists hope
Kellyanne and Schiller and then the
brass Madison McMaster and Kelly but the
family Ivanka and Jared the only thing I
can derive from that grouping is the
family's ascendant and they're not going
anywhere and in terms of the staff
change it looks very random I don't know
if you can really derive that much of a
pattern there but the pattern to me at
least seems he's putting in place people
that he trusts and that like him it's
very important for the people that
surround the president to support the
president's agenda
agree with the president's agenda and
then personally like the president we've
heard a lot of people that are kind of
doing their duty and kind of rolling
their eyes and those leaks really I
think hurt the president and do him a
very big disservice
so he's consolidating the group of
people that around him he still likes
the diversity of opinion I'm still kind
of that serves him well but at the same
time he wants to have people
that surround him that agree with him
and like him and I safe to say Kellyanne
safe and Stephen Miller's safe and Sarah
Sanders is doing an excellent job but
Trump's all about change and I don't
think that's ever gonna stop it's funny
your language safe like an episode of
survival council survived yeah so we
both picked up when you on the idea that
you said this is like a Broadway play
and to me it's not the Broadway play so
much as reality TV and if you want to
get in the show you have to get into
like the Fox greenroom because
apparently that's the stage he says oh
you journalists fake news no chaos here
it's obvious to everybody if you just
open your eyes and take a look I mean
this is three times the amount of change
in Obama's first year two times the
amount of change and let's say Ronald
Reagan's first year I mean it's we don't
see things like this and people come and
go in a way that I think is a little
unsettling
I heard killed me I'm gonna be on these
different courts in the room and if
there are adults in the room it looks
like the adults people like McMasters
who's apparently on the the gangplank
and Tillerson and now even Kelly the
idea is well who are the adults instead
he's going to people who I think are
like an echo chamber for him who simply
tell him yes man style what he wants to
hear and that's a little unsettling